Okay, let's give it another minute for folks to join, then we'll get going.
Alright, I think we've got most people — I see Dana, Marcus, James, Rachel, Kevin, Lily, Mark. Let's get started.
Can everyone see my screen alright?
Yep, looks good.
Quick agenda: I want to get through the main topic, leave room for questions, and land on clear action items before we drop. Sound good?
The question on the table: what license or governance instrument covers a skill that references traditional knowledge — a place name, a subsistence location, a story? I'll start us with the frame. Open source covers code.
It does not cover knowledge, and it is not consent.
And I'll be the friction. A bespoke license is an adoption tax. Every non-standard term is a reason a contributor or a school district's lawyer says no.
Just flagging that this touches community review and the advisory process, so loop me in when it firms up.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Good point — let's do that.
Right, that's what I meant.
Just flagging that this touches district partnerships, so loop me in when it firms up.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the CARE governance framework anyway.
Sure, I can own that.
That's fair.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
I want to see the concrete harm before we build a new instrument that we then have to defend forever.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the CARE governance framework.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Okay, yeah.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Okay, works for me.
Agreed, let's capture it.
The harm isn't abstract to the people it belongs to. If a subsistence hunting location is published under MIT, the license explicitly permits anyone to copy and redistribute it.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
That's fair.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Just flagging that this touches district partnerships, so loop me in when it firms up.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
So my question to you, Mark: when that happens, who does the community call, and what does your standard license let them do about it?
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Can you scroll up to the top of that section?
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
That matches what I was seeing on my end with community review and the advisory process.
How does this interact with the CARE governance framework, if at all?
Sure, I can own that.
Sure — one sec.
Legally? Not much. That's my honest answer. Copyright doesn't protect facts or locations well in the first place.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Okay, next thing on the agenda.
Then the standard instrument already fails the case we care about most. That's not an adoption tax argument, that's a fitness argument.
Agreed.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Yeah, exactly.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
This is why I keep pointing at CARE and at Local Contexts — the TK and Biocultural labels.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Okay, works for me.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Let's confirm in the channel.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with district partnerships.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Let's confirm in the channel.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Sure, I can own that.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Good point — let's do that.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
How does this interact with district partnerships, if at all?
Makes sense to me.
Yeah, exactly.
How does this interact with licensing and the ADR, if at all?
Okay, works for me.
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Right, that's what I meant.
Makes sense to me.
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Good point — let's do that.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
They're not a license, they're a notice layer that travels with the data and states the community's terms even where copyright is silent.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Okay, yeah.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
I don't know enough about Local Contexts to commit to a dependency on them. That's a real project we'd be leaning on.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Yep.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with district partnerships.
Could we pilot the labels on one partner community's contributions before committing platform-wide? Learn before we standardize?
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Got it.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Let's move to the next item.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Right, that's what I meant.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Yeah, exactly.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Let me scroll down to the part that matters here.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Sure, I can own that.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Let's confirm in the channel.
Makes sense to me.
How does this interact with the CARE governance framework, if at all?
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
That's fair.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Okay, works for me.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Right, that's what I meant.
Agreed, let's capture it.
That's reasonable. Let's not decide the whole thing today. Action: I'll write up CARE + Local Contexts as an option, Mark writes up the standard-license option, we compare next session.
Got it.
Fine. I still think we'll land on standard-plus-a-notice, but I'll write it up fairly.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Yeah, exactly.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Sure, I can own that.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Okay — any questions before we wrap?
One thing: how does this affect the district partnerships timeline?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
Should I loop anyone else in on the community review and the advisory process side, or is that covered?
Alright, let me read back the action items so we're aligned before we drop.
Sarah has the follow-up on the CARE governance framework — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Mark has the follow-up on licensing and the ADR — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
James has the follow-up on community review and the advisory process — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Great. I'll write it all up and drop it in the channel. Thanks everyone.